[موسيقى]
ايضا وهذه صور نشاهدها واياكم صور مباشره
من هذه
الاشتباكات بين
الجيش الاسرائيلي والقوات الاسرائيليه
وكذلك ايضا
مع فلسطينيين وكانت طبعا قد اعلنت الصحه
الفلسطينيه كما ذكرنا قبل قليل مقتله
ثلاثه فلسطينيين واصابه 30 اخرين على
الاقل برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
ونشاهد هذه المشاهد واياكم من البلده
القديمه لهذه الاشتباكات احراق اطارات
وكذلك لمواجهه بين جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وكذلك
فلسطينيين في البلده القديمه في نابلس
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني قال بانه استقبل
خمسه او استقبل 45 اصابه بالرصاص و250
حاله اختناق في نابلس سنتابع كل
التطورات بعد قليل مع مراسل العربيه من
هناك عبد الحفيظ جعوان عبد الحفيظ مرحبا
بك معي في هذه النشره يعني الصور يبدو ان
الامور تتصاعد اكثر مما كانت عليه الصباح
اليوم اولا ما الذي يحدث في البلده
القديمه كيف يمكن قراءه الوضع الان
عبد الحفيظ كيف ما زالت المواجهات متواصله
وعنيفه نعم نايف ما زالت مواجهات متواصله
وعنيفه بشكل كبير هنا في محيط البلده
القديمه في مدينه نابلس لم نستطع الاقتراب
البلده القديمه وتبعد بضعه امطار من هنا
نحن على اطراف البلده القديمه القوات
الاسرائيليه اغلقت معظم مداخل البلده
القديمه وتدور الان اشتباكات عنيفه بين
عشرات الشبان الفلسطينيين الذين خرجوا من
المدارس ومن الجامعات وبين القوات
الاسرائيليه التي تقوم بمحاصره احد
المنازل في المدينه وقامت بقصفه بالصواريخ
والذي يتحصن فيه
مجموعه من الناشطين الفلسطينيين وزاره
الصحه تتحدث الان عن نحو 300 جريح حتى هذه
اللحظه منهم 250 اختناق بالغاز ولكن
الحديث عن تقريبا 50 50 اصابه بالرصاص
الحي كما تشاهد يعني كما تش الان
نعمل شبان يقومون برشك القوات الاسرائيليه
بالحجاره بشكل مباشر
في محيط البلد القديمه هنا كنت تتحدث عن
وزاره الصحه تتحدث عن نحو
خمسين اصابه بالرصاص الحي وعن ارتقاء
ثلاثه فلسطينيين حتى هذه اللحظه هذه يعني
من استطاعت التواكم الصحيه والتواكم
الطبيه يعني انتشالهم
الحديث عن ثلاث اصابات سوف نحاول التحرك
من مكان الاقتراب اكثر نعم كما تشاهد الان
الجيش الاسرائيلي على ما يبدو بدا
بالانسحاب وهناك اطلاق نار والقاء حجاره
بشكل كثير
نعم اطلاق رصاص بشكل كثيف الان يجري نحن
نتمنى ان تكون في مكان امن عبد الحفيظ
يعني من من الرصاص او اصوات الرصاص الحي
وربما ايضا المواجهات التي هي قريبه منك
بشكل كبير يعني كما يبدو في هذه الصور لكن
ايضا على النتائج التي ذكرت الان بان
الصحه الفلسطينيه استقبلت 300 جريح منهم
250 شخصا اصيبوا باختناق وخمسون حاله
اصابه بالرصاص اسال هنا عن الحاله بينهم
حالات حرجه او اصابتهم
مزيد من الاصابات
سنشاهد مزيد من الاصابات بما انه يعني كما
تشاهد الان المركبات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
علقت وسط الجموع الفلسطينيين والشبان
الذين يقومون برشقها بالحجاره على مدخل
مدينه نابلس على ما يبدو هناك انسحاب جزئي
للقوات الاسرائيليه هي تخرج الان من محيط
البلده القديمه موسط البلده القديمه الى
الاحياء المجاوره والشبان يلاحقونها
بالحجاره وايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي يقوم
باطلاق الرصاص على هؤلاء الشبان وبالتالي
كما نشاهد ايضا سيارات الاسعاف تتحرك بشكل
كثيف في محيط المكان وبالتالي يعني متوقع
ايضا تسجيل مزيد من الاصابات كنت اتحدث
انه وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه تحدثت عن مقتل
ثلاثه فلسطينيين حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن
الرقم مرشح للارتفاع نظرا لان مكان
العمليات يعني مكان حدوث العمليات كان
داخل البلده القديمه في البيت المحصن ولا
نعرف كان هناك اخبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
قام باغتيال شابين فلسطينيين داخل هذا
المبنى وربما اخذ جثامينهم هذا داخل
المبنى ولا نعرف ايضا لان الطواقم الصحيه
لم تستطع انتشال المزيد من الضحايا داخل
البلده القديمه نتحدث عن مسن فلسطيني عمره
72 عاما ايضا قتل برصاص جيش الاسرائيلي
وهناك ايضا طفل فلسطيني وبالتالي الرقم
مرشح للارتفاع اعتقد بعد قليل ستتجلى
الامور اكثر يعني هناك الان ما زالت يعني
كما نشاهد ربما الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا
بالانسحاب بالفعل كان هناك اخبار ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي انهى عمليته التي بدات منذ
الساعه العاشره نتحدث عن ثلاث ساعات من
عمليه متواصله في هذه المدينه المزدحمه
بشكل كبير مدينه نابلس من كبرى المدن
الفلسطينيه دخلها في وسط النهار دوام
مدارس دوام جامعات وبالتالي عدد الاصابات
مرشح للارتفاع وهذا ايضا يبرر على هذا
العدد الكبير من الاصابات التي حدثت في
هذه المدينه
اعتقد ان الامور يعني ربما الجيش بالفعل
انسحب
هناك كما تشاهد يعني السيارات الاسعاف
تقوم ايضا
بنقل اصابه على ما يبدو في هذا المكان
ايضا وقعت
وكما نسمع ايضا
[تصفيق]
نسمع ايضا اصوات اطلاق مارك في محيط
البلده القديمه عموما هذا الحي الشرقي من
البلده القديمه ايضا على ما يبدو ان
الاشتباكات المسلحه ما زالت متواصله ربما
من الجهه الاخرى من البلده القديمه في
مدينه نابلس ربما الجيش الاسرائيلي
نعم ربما الجيش الاسرائيلي انسحب بشكل
جزئي من هذه الجهه من الجهه الشرقيه من
مدينه نابلس ولكن ربما من الجهه الاخرى
مازال الجيش الاسرائيلي موجود
سوف نحاول الاقتراب اكثر لمعرفه ما الذي
يجري وحصيله هذه العمليه الاسرائيليه التي
الحقيقه لقت ادانات واسعه من قبل السلطه
الفلسطينيه التي يعني ترى ان في مثل هذا
الاقتحام الكبير للجيش الاسرائيلي في هذا
الوقت من
من اليوم يعني لمدينه كبرى مثل مدينه
نابلس هذا استفزاز كبير وهو يعني تصعيد
مقصود من قبل اسرائيل تصعيد مقصود بالنسبه
لجهود التهدئه التي كانت تسعى اليها
الولايات المتحده والتعديد من الاطراف
العربيه والاطراف الاوروبيه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وياتي هنا السؤال ايضا حتى عبد
الحفيظ يعني هل كانت هذه العمليه عمليه
مفاجئه نحن كنا نرصد خلال الايام الماضيه
وسطات ايضا
للتهدئه هناك وسلطات امريكيه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
تحديدا بعد ان يعني قيل ان هناك قناه
اتصال سريه بين السلطه الفلسطينيه وبين
اسرائيل وبين جهود امريكيه نجحت في يعني
منع التصويت في مجلس الامن على موضوع
الاستيطان وبالتالي قيل ان الوسطات بدات
تنجح الوصفات الامريكيه وان تهدئه يعني
بدات تسري شيئا فشيئا في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وان احد بنود هذه الاتفاقيات
التي ترعاها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هي وقف الاقتحامات الكبرى للمدن
الفلسطينيه لان من شانها يعني مثل هذه
الاقتحامات التي توقع هذا العدد الكبير من
الضحايا والعدد الاصابات هي التي تشعل
فتيل المواجهه وبالتالي نرى ردود فعل
فلسطينيه من ناحيه عمليات عسكريه وعمليات
طعن وما الى ذلك وبالتالي يستغرب وكما
سمعنا منذ الصباح يعني يستغرب مسؤولون
فلسطينيون ان تكون اسرائيل بمثل هذه
العمليه وسط كل هذه الجهود التي كانت
تتحدث عن
تعهد اسرائيل بتراجع عن اقتحام المدن
وبشكل واسع وبشكل كبير فما بالك باقتحام
مدينه نابلس كبرى المدن الفلسطينيه في وسط
النهار
ضمن تواجد هذا العدد الكبير من المدنيين
طلاب المدارس
طلاب الجامعات السوق الشرقي تحديدا الذي
اقتحمته القوات الاسرائيليه وشريان الحياه
في مدينه نابلس يعج بالمتسوقين والماره
والمتفضعين وبالتالي
اعتبرته الحكومه الفلسطينيه والسلطه
الفلسطينيه نصف لكل هذه التفاهمات التي
حدثت على كل حال منذ اقتحام مخيم عقبه جبر
حيث تم قتل خمسه فلسطينيين فيه منذ نحو
اسبوعين او اكثر لم نرى مثل هذه العمليات
الكبرى ولكن بشكل عام منذ بدايه هذا العام
القوات الاسرائيليه قتلت اكثر من 52
فلسطيني في عمليات مشابهه وبالتالي هناك
تصعيد كبير منذ بدايه هذا العام طبعا هذا
التصعيد الميداني يضاف الى تصعيد في موضوع
الاستيطان موضوع هدم المنازل موضوع
الاعتقالات والكثير من الموضوعات الاخرى
ذات العلاقه المتواصله العلاقه المتشابكه
بين اسرائيل الذي الجانب الاسرائيلي الذي
ينفذ احتلاله بشكل مباشر في الضفه الغربيه
وبين الفلسطينيين بالنسبه على اوسع ايضا
كذلك عبد الحفيظ ليس نابلس لكل طبعا
المناطق
الفلسطينيه هل هناك عمليات اقتحام مشابهه
لما حدث اليوم في نابلس رصدت خلال الايام
الماضي او اليوم ايضا حتى الحقيقه
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيين بدايه العام الغريب في مثل
هناك عمليات اقتحام متواصله ولكن عاده هذه
عمليات الاقتحام تجري في منتصف الليل
الساعه الثالثه الرابعه فجرا عمليات
اعتقال ولكن ان يجري اقتحام المدينه وسط
النهار الساعه العاشره صباحا في ظل هذا
العدد الكبير من الناس
والماره والمتسوقين والمدنيين هذا تصعيد
خطير تعتبره السلطه الفلسطينيه وايضا من
شانها ان ياتي بردود الفعل وذلك لانه يسقط
العديد من من الضحايا يعني بصائرات
الاسعاف ما زالت منذ الصباح لم تهدا حتى
وان هناك النقل لبعض الاصابات ونحن قادمون
من رام الله شاهدنا نقل اصابات من من
مدينه نابلس الى المدن الاخرى وهناك
نداءات للتبرع بالدم في مستشفى رفيديا
وغيرها من المستشفيات في مدينه نابلس
وبالتالي عدد الاصابات والضحايا من
المتوقع ان يرتفع بشكل كبير وهذا يعني من
شانها ان يكون بمثابه فتيل الانفجار تسعى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاط الدوليه
وحتى ان السلطه الفلسطينيه رسميه الغير
معنيه بتوير او بالدخول في مثل هذا التوتر
بشكل كبير ولكن على ما يبدو ان للجانب
الاسرائيلي او القوات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه راي اخر هي تنفذ سياسه محدده
وسياسات اغتيال هذا اليوم يعني كان هناك
استهداف لهذه الخليه الفلسطينيه كان وهم
يعني مقاتلون من عرين الاسود تحديدا هذه
المجموعه التي كانت يعني تشتهر بشكل كبير
في مدينه نابلس صحيح ان معظم هؤلاء
المقاتلين تم اغتيالهم في المدينه ولكن
ايضا هناك بقايا لهذه المجموعات عرين
الاسود وبالتالي كان هناك قوات خاصه قد
اقتحمت المنزل في البلده القديمه وقامت
بمحاصرته بعدها دخلت هذه القوات الكبيره
التي قامت ايضا بقصف المنزل ولا نعرف مصير
من كان من في داخل المنزل من هؤلاء
المقاتلين
يعني نحن نشير لهذه الصور الصور المتداوله
للاطقم الطبي الفلسطينيه وهي تحاول الدخول
الى
منطقه البلده القديمه في نابلس تحاول طبعا
انقاذ المصابين وكذلك
المقتنقين ايضا كذلك جراء عمليه الاقتحام
الاسرائيليه تابعنا قبل قليل الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني ذكر بانه استقبل 45 حاله
اصابه بالرصاص و250 او 250 حاله اختناق في
نابلس الزميل عبد الحفيظ ذكر ايضا كذلك
قبل قليل بان السيارات الاسعاف تنقل
المصابين من نابلس الى مستشفيات رام الله
نعيد التذكير بهذه الصور المتداوله لاطقم
طبيه فلسطينيه تحاول الدخول الى البلده
القديمه
بنابلس في محاوله لانقاذ المصابين
والمقتنقين ايضا كذلك جراء
الغاز او قنابل الغاز المسيله كذلك لدموع
التي طبعا اطلقتها القوات الاسرائيليه
داخل مدينه نابلس
تحديدا في البلده القديمه
اذا هذه صور نتابعها العمليه التي
تفضل عبد الحفيظ
نعم نائب فقط احدث الارقام وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه تتحدث الان عن مقتل خمسه
فلسطينيين جرى هذه العمليه وهناك ايضا نحو
عشر اصابات بشكل حرج للغايه والعمليه
تقريبا انتهت القوات الاسرائيليه بالفعل
المشهد الذي شاهدتموه من قبل دقائق كان هو
مشهد انسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه من
المدينه اذا وزاره الصحه تقول ان عدد
الضحايا ارتفع الى خمسه وعدد الاصابات 45
اصابه بالرصاص الحي هذه نقلت الى المستشفى
بعدها بعضها اصابات حرجه بينها عشر اصابات
حرجه طيب في هذه الصور التي المتداوله
التي تابعناها عبد الحفيظ هي المحاوله
انقاذ
المصابين روما داخل البلده القديمه اسال
هنا عن المسعفين هل استطاعوا الدخول الى
نابلس بشكل
سهل انه هناك صعوبه بالغه يعني كما تنقلها
لنا هذه الصور المتداوله في الدخول الى
البلده القديمه في محاوله انقاذ طبعا
المصابين ونقلهم الى المستشفى
[موسيقى]
القديمه نايف كانت مغلقه بشكل كامل منعت
الطواقم الصحيه حتى ان الصحافه منعت من
الدخول وهناك ثالث اصابات بين الصحافه
منها مراسل تلفزيون فلسطين محمد الخطيب
الذي اصيب بالرصاص الحي بعد ان استهدفته
القوات الاسرائيليه بشكل مباشر خلال
محاوله الدخول الى داخل البلده القديمه
لمعرفه ما يجري وبالتالي المشاهد التي
شاهدتموها
نعم المشاهد التي شاهدتموها كانت محاوله
الطواقم الصحيه طواقم الطبيه الدخول الى
داخل ازقه البلده القديمه لانتشال بعض
المصابين وبعض الضحايا الان اعتقد ان
الطواقم الطبيه تمكنت من الدخول لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد انسحب بالفعل وقد انهى
عمليته ممتاز
يعني دعنا فقط نحدث الارقام مره اخرى معك
عبد الحفيظ يعني الان نتحدث عن خمسه قتله
فلسطينيين نتحدث عن 200
وخمسين اصابه بينها 45 اصابه بالرصاص
وكذلك ايضا 250 حاله اختناق عشر اصابات
حرجه حتى الان بين من اصيبوا بالرصاص هذه
الارقام دقيقه
عفوا نايف لم اسمع سؤال كنت اتحدث عن
الارقام احدث معك الارقام التي اعلنتها
الصحه الفلسطينيه نتحدث عن خمسه فلسطينيين
قتلوا نتحدث عن 10 اصابات حرجه نتحدث عن
45 اصابه بالرصاص و250 حاله اقتناق
نعم صحيح هذا نايف هذا يعني وفق وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه دعني اقرا اخر تحديث
بالنسبه لاسماء الضحايا عدنان سماره 72
عاما وهو شخص مسن كان له فيديو هو احد
الذين كانوا يتسوقون من من السوق عمره 72
عاما وهناك شاب اخر عمره 25 وايضا شاب
عمره 33 وهناك الطفل وهناك نعم كما قلنا
يعني وزاره الصحه تتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد
الضحايا الى خمسه وهناك نحو خمسين اصابه
بالرصاص الحي بعضها اصابات خطيره اضافه
للعديد من الاصابات نحو 250 اصابه
بالاخلاق او بالرصاص المطاطي تم معالجتها
ميدانيا خلال هذه العمليه التي بدات
الساعه العاشره بتوقيت فلسطين وانتهت
الساعه الواحده نتحدث عن عمليه عسكريه في
كبرى المدن الفلسطينيه استمرت ثلاث ساعات
واوقعت هذا العدد الكبير من الظفور قبل
قليل ايضا كذلك عبد الحفيظ عن اصابه احد
الصحفيين في هذه
هل كانت هذه الاصابه اصابه بالغه عبد
الحفيظ حول يعني او مما لديك من معلومات
حتى اللحظه
نعم هو مراسل التلفزيون فلسطين التلفزيون
الوطني اصيب بالرصاص الحي في يده واصابته
متوسطه ونقل الى المستشفى طبعا اصيب اضافه
الى اثنين من زملائه الصحفيين واثناء وذلك
اثناء محاولتهم الدخول او تغطيه ما يجري
في البذره القديمه حيث اشتكى الصحفيون من
استهدافهم بشكل مباشر من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه داخل البلده القديمه طبعا
نايف اود ان يشير الى ان يعني ايضا شهدت
المدينه اشتباكات عنيفه كان هناك العديد
من المقاتلين والعديد من البيانات
العسكريه التي صدرت من المقاتلين داخل
البلده القديمه من من الكثير من الفصائل
الذين تصدوا لهذا الاقتحام بالرصاص الحي
وبالاشتباكات المسلحه هذا اضافه للمئات
الشبان الذين قاموا برشق القوات
الاسرائيليه بالحجاب عبد الحفيظ الى الى
ماذا يشير يعني هذا النهج الجديد من قبل
القوات الاسرائيليه في اقتحام
نابلس في وضح النهار في وقت مثل هذا هي
بالعاده يعني تتم هذه الاقتحامات في متاخر
من من الليل او ايضا في الصباح الباكر جدا
يعني وفق ما سمعته من مسؤولين فلسطينيين
قبل ق
ليل كلجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح اللجنه
التنفيذيه قالوا ان اسرائيل بهذه السياسه
يعني تريد ان توصل رساله
لاولًا جمهور الحكومه الاسرائيليه الذي
يعتبر من اليمين واليمين المتطرف ان يعني
اسرائيل ماضيه في سياساتها اتجاهها
الفلسطينيين ان الامن هو اساس بالنسبه
اليها لانها يعني عندما تقتحم مثل هذه
المدن تدعي انهم انها يعني توقف قنابل
موكوته او يعني تستهدف مطاردين فلسطينيين
يشكلون خطرا عليها وان اسرائيل يعني ماضيه
بسياسه احاديه الجانب مثل الاستيطان مثل
هدم المنازل وايضا سياسه احاديه الجانب
ذات علاقه بامنها فقط ولا تهتم ولا تكترث
بالوصفات الامريكيه او الجهود المبذوله
الدوليا للتهدئه او جهود يعني تقريب وجهات
النظر التي تبدلها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بين الفلسطينيين لحتى ان نائب
كان هناك حديث ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه استطاعت الوصول الى صيغه لاعاده
تنسي بين الجانبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
ولكن في مثل هذه العمليه فاننا نعود الى
المربع الاول الذي بدا هذا العام وكما قلت
لك منذ بدايه هذا العام قتلت اسرائيل اكثر
من 52 فلسطيني والرقم سوف يزداد بالتاكيد
وايضا عشرات الجرحى عشرات المنازل التي
هدمت وايضا هناك مستوطنات تبنى بشكل كبير
وبالتالي هذا التعبير واضح عن الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وتوجه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
التي تحوي وزراء متطرفين ومستوطنين طبعا
هذا انقله كله على لسان القياده
الفلسطينيه التي تتابع منذ الصباح ما يجري
وتكون يعني اعطاء تصريحات لوسائل الاعلام
حول هذه الامور عبد الحفيظ يعني دعنا فقط
نتابع هذه الصور هي صور لعمليه اخلاء
مصابين فلسطينيين بعد اقتحام الجيش
الاسرائيلي للبلده القديمه في نابلس اذا
هذه الصور متداوله لعمليه اخلاء مصابين
فلسطينيين اصيبوا طبعا برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي داخل البلده القديمه في نابلس
مراسل العربيه قبل قليل الزميل عبد الحفيظ
جعوان كان قد افاد بارتفاع عدد القتلى
برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه في نابلس الى
خمسه فلسطينيين وفقا للصحه الفلسطينيه
وبان هناك 45 اصابه
بالرصاص من بينها طبعا هذه الصور التي
نتابعها ومحاوله انقاذ احد المصابين
الفلسطيني برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه في
البلده القديمه بنابلس تحدث الزميل عبد
الحفيظ جعوان كذلك عن عشر اصابات حرجه بين
طبعا الفلسطينيين الذين اصيبوا جراء
طبعا هذه العمليه عمليه عمليه اقتحام
الاسرائيليه في البلده القديمه في نابلس
هذه الصور ايضا كذلك ربما للانسحاب انسحاب
الجيش الاسرائيلي من هذه المنطقه من
البلده القديمه كما ذكر قبل قليل ايضا
مراسل العربيه
هناك الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ذكر بانه
استقبل خمسه واربعين اصابه بالرصاص بينهم
طبعا بينهم عشر اصابات اصابات حرجه وكذلك
ايضا اصوات اطلاق الرصاص كنا قد تبعنا
معكم في بدايه هذه النشره والتي كانت يعني
بشكل
مستمر في البلده القديمه في نابلس وهذه
ربما ايضا صور من الاشتباكات بين
قوات
القوات الاسرائيليه كذلك ايضا وبين
فلسطينيين محاولات ايضا لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه بعد اصابه طبعا كما ذكرنا 250 فلس
جراء هذه العمليه
اذا بالعوده مره اخرى الى عبد الحفيظ يعني
بالنسبه للقوات الاسرائيليه في هذه
العمليه هل اعلنت عن تسجيل اي اصابات حتى
هذه اللحظه
عبد الحفيظ هل تسمعني اسمع السؤال ولكن
نعم اذا كنت تسال عن اصابات الجانب
الاسرائيلي حسب ما وردنا حتى الان هناك
اصابه جندي خلال هذه الاشتباكات التي
شهدتها مدينه نابلس لا نعرف طبيعه الاصابه
حتى الان يعني هذا ما نقلته مصادر صحفيه
اسرائيليه لا يوجد بيان عسكري واضح من
الجانب الاسرائيلي حول نتائج هذه العمليه
ولا نعرف دعنا نؤكد لنعرف مصير الناشطين
او المقاتلين الذين كانوا يتحصلوا داخل
هذا البيت الذي استهدفته القوات
الاسرائيليه بالصواريخ ان كان تم اغتيالهم
واخذ جثامينهم ام انه توكلوا من الفرار
حتى هذه اللحظه لا معلومات مؤكده انتظر
بيان عسكري وان كانت المعلومات
الاسرائيليه او حسب وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه تقول ان الكويت الاسرائيليه
قامت باغتيالها هؤلاء يعني هذين الناشطين
لا نعرف ما الذي يجري بعد قليل سوف نحاول
التوجه الى مكان العمليه لمكان المنزل
الذي تمت فيه العمليه والذي قصف بالصواريخ
عمليا الان
الانقاذ والدفاع المدني تحاول الوصول الى
داخل البر القديمه الى المكان المستهدف
لازاله ربما بعض المتفجرات او ان كانت بعض
بقايا الذخيره التي قد تشكل خطرا على حياه
الناس الاعاديين وربما ايضا اعاده وصل
شبكات المياه
والكهرباء التي عاده ما نرى تضررا كبيرا
لها بسبب العنيف في القوات الاسرائيليه
لهذه لهذه البلده القديمه التي يعني بلده
عمرها الاف السنين بلده قديم والبنيه
التحتيه فيها يعني ضعيفه للغايه طيب نتابع
فقط هذه الصور متداوله ايضا لانسحاب
القوات الاسرائيليه من مدينه نابلس تحديدا
من البلده القديمه بعد ان اقتحمت ظهره
اليوم
واوقعت طبعا حتى هذه اللحظه خمسه
فلسطينيين لقوا حتفهم طبعا في هذه العمليه
عشر اصابات حرجه كما ذكر الزميل عبد
الحفيظ جعوان قبل قليل 45 اصابه ايضا
بالرصاص 250 حاله اختناق على كل حال نشكر
الزميل عبد الحفيظ جوان مراسل العربيه من
نابلس الذي شاركنا في هذه النشره شكرا
لكمي ولطف المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]